the number of commercial fishermen here
in waukegan went from over a dozen
down to a handful and then as of the the
early to mid 90s just the one in in
atkinson fishery you can see as
the economy changed down here at the
harbor front it changed for waukegan and
changed for the local economy in general
it's been fascinating to watch that
change over the many decades that i that
i've been here
[Music]
commercial fishing as we know it began
from the day european settlement started
in the great lakes region what happened
is that as the 1800s
plotted along
you went from in the early part of the
1800s small scale fishing operations
to large-scale operations that were
borderline industrial and the fishery
was intensely harvested it came right up
the ramp uh that we're seeing right now
a little bit different than what's
configured today
big tubs of perch and
whitefish lake trout and chubs coming in
as time progressed the
limits of what could actually be fished
were
tightened
and then ultimately
perch was so minimal along with chubs
that it wasn't viable so we had about
anywhere from 16 to 55 commercial
fishers
um and that would have been from like
1946 to 1974.
and then
the department
implemented a limited entry commercial
fishery and dropped it down to three
they held the lottery and then the top
three were picked and then we kept that
list going so if somebody dropped out a
new fishery business would be contacted
and they could come back in
that really struck the heartstrings of
so many people
in the states uh specifically in the
city because all those people were
hoping to get
one of the licenses there were a lot of
people who were put out of business
seven billion dollars is the uh the best
number we have right now for the value
the economic impact of great lakes
fisheries the big majority of that is
sport fishing and all the money that's
spent on boats and bait and lures and
all that those groups were not
supportive of commercial fishing
not everybody started out being you know
charter fishermen or commercial
fishermen
believe it or not before my dad was a
fisherman he was a a race boat builder
for outboard marine corporation so as
the fishing really waned they kind of
fell back on those you know those
professions
waukegan today is a much different place
than it was you know back in the 80s and
90s
unfortunately the commercial fishermen
being
the the vast minority ultimately didn't
have the the money or the political
influence to survive right and
subsequently you know they went out of
business in the in the late 90s
specifically 1997 my dad received a call
from
the illinois dnr at the time
and and they informed us that they were
cutting our quota dramatically back so
my dad pivoted and moved and focused
mostly on the on the charter fishing and
so that's really what sustained us for
many years for us
uh early on
was to abandon the commercial fishing
side of it and focus on the restaurant
so that's what's
still here today is that
decision that was made a long time ago
to get out of commercial fishing and put
the emphasis on the restaurant business
they adapt to what is out there and
what's thriving and what's not that's
the um the nature of the beast with
commercial fishing there are operations
that might set up a um a restaurant
or a shop
that's mainly supplied by their own
commercial fishing vessels so you're
seeing some adaptation as well now it's
never going to replace the the larger
scales and the restaurant markets and
the export of very wholesome great lakes
fish
but you do see some that are adapting as
well to local markets i think there's
room for everybody to
partake in the fisheries and these big
lakes you know lake trout were an
important commercial species in the 60
years of stocking and now they're
finally starting to recruit
naturally so we'll see we'll just have
to see where it goes in the future
there's something very fulfilling about
commercial fishing and
it's a tight-knit family as well you
know once once you get it in your dna
and your blood you don't want to stop
because it is is quite fulfilling
you know my dad made very clear
that you know keep keep the boat keep
the equipment and everything else
because eventually the lake is going to
come back and it'll come back to the
point where it will support a commercial
fishery again
so you would you would return dick
marshall fishing in a heartbeat oh yeah
this you know as i shared earlier
there's there's nothing like fishing on
lake michigan it's it's a
it's a passion